Jacqueline à fond excepté le totem du
barreau Henri Leclerc rares sont les
avocats qui fassent à ce point
l'unanimité auprès de leur père or à
l'évocation de votre nom c'est toujours
un concert de louange comment expliquer
vous ça je n'en sais rien je pense aussi
peut-être que je fais l'objet d'une
certaine bienveillance
peut-être parce que j'ai traversé des
moments difficiles voilà moi j'ai une
piste à vous proposer mais de ton côté
vos qualités professionnelles largement
éprouvée et reconnu votre légendaire
discrétion dans un milieu à Fort ego n'y
serait peut-être pas pour quelque chose
justement
peut-être je pense que lorsque l'on
s'expose on s'expose et aux critiques
également et donc je m'expose pas si
souvent que cela je porte peut-être
moins le flan à la à la critique ou
jalousie beaucoup de cheveux de choses
se passent dans dans nos métiers dans
tous les métiers probablement d'envie
voilà alors Emmanuel
dit que et amis et amis que la
discrétion fait partie de vos gènes et
de cette génération oui c'est vrai que
on est peut-être une génération plus
plus discrète moi en ce qui me concerne
j'ai toujours eu une
façon de de régler cette question
c'est est-ce que ça sert mon client ou
pas voilà et comme je pense que en
définitive notre notre rôle notre
mission elle s'exerce dans les tribunaux
devant les tribunaux devant les juges et
en aucun cas dans une arène médiatique
défendre un ancien président de la
République est-ce que c'est le même
exercice que défendre ça mobilise
toujours les mêmes les mêmes ressorts
c'est à dire que moi je pense que ce
métier on doit le faire avec une forte
capacité de d'indignation de combat
c'est à dire que moi j'ai l'impression
que chaque défense de chaque homme ou de
chaque femme c'est à chaque fois un
combat pour plus de justice il y a
évidemment des différences et puis il y
a pour l'essentiel beaucoup de points
beaucoup de points communs alors vous
avez été l'avocat de Nicolas Sarkozy
entre autres vous êtes toujours vous
êtes aux yeux du public en tout cas
l'avocate des puissants de Charles
Pasqua Serge Dassault Ali Bongo Laurent
Gbagbo à Jean-Marie Messier de Nicolas
Sarkozy ont la cité Alexandre Benalla en
passant par Nicolas Hulot Patrick Poivre
d'Arvor ou encore Damien Abad d'ailleurs
comment défendons à l'ère de Mito et des
gilets jaunes on doit les défendre
puisque jamais oui ce que jamais parce
que j'ai le sentiment aujourd'hui que
on est dans une heure où effectivement
on veut se passer de la médiation de de
la Justice de la médiation de la règle
de la médiation de la loi de la
médiation de cet espace sacralisé qui
fait que on a une décision qui est le
fruit de règles d'une procédure une
décision de justice n'existe pas si elle
n'est pas recueillie selon des règles
qui sont arrêtées par la loi et la
justice directe immédiate pour moi n'est
pas une justice donc plus que jamais il
faut se battre parce que
il y a des dérives qui à mon avis sont
inquiétantes
je pense que beaucoup de nos grands
principes sont en train de voler en
éclat alors justement diriez-vous que
l'époque entre en dissonance avec les
droits de la défense plus que jamais oui
c'est quand même c'est quand même la
grande époque
de l'accusation je trouve que c'est
quand même la mode de l'accusation
l'interpellation la modique de la
dénonciation sauvage publique sans ces
règles qui font la justice sans
lesquelles la justice n'existe pas la
justice est évidemment imparfaite elle
doit progresser toujours elle doit être
dénoncée lorsqu'elle a des failles elle
doit être améliorée elle doit en
permanence être questionnée enfin je la
prends pas pour pour une institution qui
serait parfaite et idéal loin de là je
me bats tous les jours pour que cette
justice soit meilleure et à chacune de
mes affaires je pense que j'agis pour
cela mais mais si vous voulez la justice
reste la justice elle ne peut être
remplacée par rien d'autre et il n'y a
pas encore une fois de possibilités de
son affranchir et je pense que c'est ça
que je trouve dangereux c'est à dire que
au nom de combat qui sont évidemment
nobles légitimes beaux nécessaires et
tous les qualificatifs possibles on
vient
mobilisez des ressorts qui parfois
m'inquiètent voilà de de volonté de
morts sociales enfin la réalité c'est
que aujourd'hui point de salut pour les
personnes qui ont été un jour accusées
dans leur vie de d'affaires jugés ou pas
jugé ou pas c'est quand même important
de le rappeler c'est à dire que ces
personnes n'ont plus le droit de vivre
non plus le droit d'aller dans un salon
littéraire elles n'ont plus le droit
d'être vue à un spectacle donc je trouve
que il y a une dérive en réalité d'une
justice populiste vous évoquez j'imagine
PPDA et Nicolas Hulot on va en parler
mais j'aimerais d'abord vous faire
intervenir sur cette citation le procès
et d'abord une cérémonie de parole il
met des mots
à la place de la violence une peine à la
place de la vengeance et de l'argent la
place de la souffrance c'est le sens
profond la justice que de substituer à
l'événement du crime un autre événement
celui du procès écrivent dans victimes
et après Arthur des nouveaux et Antoine
Garapon alors comment justement les
victimes peuvent être reconnues dans
leur souffrance sans procès quand les
faits sont prescrits ou les preuves
insuffisantes alors écoutez c'est
formidable que vous citiez Arthur des
nouveaux et Antoine Garapon Antoine
Garapon qui est un ancien magistrat
philosophe
je trouve que cette citation est très
juste et en fait si vous voulez je pense
qu'il y a un leurre à vouloir entretenir
il y a un temps pour tout il y a le
temps de la justice et puis il y a la
loi qui au bout d'un certain temps qui
est devenu très long c'était
probablement nécessaire on a rallongé
considérablement de prescriptions qui
vient vous dire vous n'avez plus le
droit de juger un homme et donc on vous
demande de condamner socialement un
homme que la loi interdit de juger et si
vous voulez un homme que la loi
interdite de juger c'est un homme qui ne
sera jamais condamné un homme qui ne
sera jamais condamné c'est un homme qui
ne peut pas être présenté comme un
coupable ce n'est pas possible et la
réalité c'est que un homme qui n'a pas
été déclaré coupable est un innocence et
ça je pense que nous avons nous à un
rôle une responsabilité je pense que
tout le monde porte une responsabilité
sur le fait d'entretenir certaines
plaignantes victimes peut-être parmi
parmi elles dans les plaignantes il y a
beaucoup de victimes c'est une évidence
mais dans le leurre que finalement il
faut la vengeance c'est une question de
justice là c'est une question de
vengeance et bien non moi je pense que
le deuil comme on dit ce mot j'aime pas
trop d'ailleurs c'est assez galvaudé
mais mes doigts existaient en dehors de
cela mais comment se reconstruire quand
les fans sont pas caractérisées quand
ils sont prescrits j'ai eu des moins ce
que je pense profondément c'est que on
doit
inciter les femmes quelles qu'elles
soient les hommes qui sont victimes à
déposer plainte le plus rapidement
possible c'est quand même le meilleur
moyen que la justice fonctionne et quand
je dis le blurateur possible les délais
sont longs je veux dire qu'on leur
demande pas de faire ça dans dans les 24
heures ni dans les six mois ni même dans
les 5 ans donc voilà il faut que les
femmes
se dirigent vers le plus nombreux
possible vers les portes des
commissariats vers la justice qu'elle
conserve les preuves qu'elle conserve
les éléments les textos qu'elles ont
envoyé à leurs amis les éléments
éventuellement pour pouvoir faire en
sorte que ces faits soit jugés le jour
ils ne peuvent plus être c'est la loi
c'est même personne qui vient de vous
dire distinction c'est probablement les
mêmes qui se sont battus contre les
tribunaux d'exception et les
juridictions d'exception est-ce qu'on
veut faire dans ce cas du 6 exceptions
non il y a des lois alors on peut les
considérer parfois un parfaites
également on a on a des moyens qui sont
ceux effectivement de l'arsenal
législatif pour éventuellement les faire
bouger la politique les députés il y a
des institutions mais si vous voulez
pour moi on arrive quand même à une
justice populiste c'est à dire que on
vient finalement
faire des dénonciations sauvages défier
les institutions moi je les combats tous
les jours j'ai trop insuffisante voilà
mais et finalement s'affranchit de la
loi et de la règle et je trouve ça
dangereux qu'auriez-vous envie de
répondre à Adèle à NL qui désespèrent de
la justice de son pays un viol sur 10
aboutit à une condamnation point de
telle qu'en est-il des 9 autres qu'en
est-il de toutes ces vies si la justice
veut être à l'image de la société elle
doit impérativement se remettre en
question évidemment que la justice se
remettre en question elle s'est quand
même déjà pas même mise en remise en
question pardon sur ces sur ces sujets
là et moi ce que ce que je lui réponds
c'est que lorsque j'accompagne des
femmes parce que j'en accompagne aussi
on sait parcours là qui sont certes des
parcours douloureux et difficiles je
pense qu'on a on a un rôle je pense que
vous vous avez un relais journaliste que
nous avocats nous avons un rôle c'est
celui de leur expliquer qu'il y a des
règles il y a des lois et que s'il y a
une plainte à déposer parce qu'elle
souhaite la déposer parce qu'elles
estiment qu'elles ont été victimes de
faits elles doivent et nous sommes là
pour les accompagner mais il faut leur
expliquer que au bout de cela il y aura
une décision de justice voilà et cette
décision de justice elle sera peut-être
difficile à accepter ou pas mais elle
sera celle qui sera rendue selon des
lois qui sont des lois qui nous
protègent tous qui qui nous protégeront
tous Demain à qui protégeront ces femmes
leurs enfants leurs frères etc donc je
pense qu'il faut accepter cette justice
avec ses imperfections là parce que il
n'y a pas mieux la justice ce que
j'aimerais essayer de voir avec vous
c'est comment sortir de cette quadrature
de cercle avec d'un côté des victimes
qui se sentent méprisées de l'autre des
accusés qui sont condamnés sans autre
forme de procès comment on en sort je
pense qu'on a tous à agir je pense qu'il
y a
qu'il y a quelque chose à faire à
accepter et comprendre
aux personnes qui sont qui sont victimes
qui sont plaignants ou plaignant je
pense aussi que la presse a un rôle à
jouer je pense que aujourd'hui je vois
la place énorme qui a été donné dans des
quotidiens d'information sur ces sujets
les premières pour sortir promouvoir des
livres bon et la place qui qui est donné
à côté de cela à ceux qui se défendent
elle est à la fois dérisoire et
lorsqu'ils osent prendre la parole une
fois mais ils en entendent parler
pendant deux ans au point que on leur
dit mais arrêtez de prendre la parole
donc je crois qu'il y a toute une remise
en question il y a toute une toute une
éducation à refaire qui est en train de
voler en éclat sur le le fait que ce
n'est pas parce qu'on vient rappeler la
règle la loi les principes que l'on
porte atteinte à des combats encore une
fois le noble et légitime quoi les deux
peuvent coexister il faut que ça se
rende compte il faut que les
journalistes laissent plus de place à ça
il faut qu'ils écrivent eux-mêmes dans
leurs articles que oui c'est comme ça un
homme qui est dont les ne peuvent pas
être jugés parce que la loi interdit de
les juger parce que non on pourra jamais
dire qu'il est coupable voilà jamais
c'est pas c'est comme ça il faut que les
victimes qui veulent s'exprimer et
conscience de cela et vous savez je me
dis de temps en temps que on entend
beaucoup de femmes qui viennent dire que
elles ont mis 30 ans à réaliser que ce
qui s'était passé ce soir là c'était
peut-être pas non plus une relation
normale etc bon et qui invoque aussi
traumatique oui alors la ministre
traumatique mais moi ce que ce que qui
est un peu remise en question je pense
que l'emprise existe que la musique
traumatique existe mais je pense que ce
sont des concepts qui ont été vraiment
galvaudé et que si vous voulez on peut
aussi interroger ces femmes je veux dire
c'est une femme chez une femme on peut
tout avoir des mauvais souvenirs
peut-être voilà mais à un moment donné
si elle-même on y trente ans à se dire
que finalement la façon dont les choses
s'étaient pas ces jours là c'est
peut-être pas normal mais qu'on peut
aussi se dire que la personne qui a
partagé cette relation là n'a pas eu
cette conscience là non plus enfin je
pense que les choses quand on parle de
ces affaires de viol là parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'autres affaires de viol dont
on parle très peu finalement que moi
j'accompagne de temps en temps celle-ci
elle
occupent beaucoup moins les une des
journaux voilà mais ces affaires là
n'ont pas parce que c'est de celle-ci
dont on parle et bien je pense que on
peut aussi interroger cela donc on est
dans une espèce de vision manichéenne le
blindman alors sur des sujets qui sont
infiniment complexes des des faits qui
sont revisités des années plus tard à
l'aune de de
d'évolution que je trouve par ailleurs
complètement souhaitable et des
situations mais voilà rien n'est aussi
simple que ça et je pense que cette
nuance là ce sera bien qu'elle oui
qu'elle ressurgissent chez les uns et
chez les autres la cour d'appel de
Versailles a exhumé récemment une
jurisprudence de la Cour de cassation
datant de 2005 indiquant que si des
faits prescrit s'inscrivent en lien
précis avec d'autres faits non prescrits
la justice peut mener son cours sans se
soucier des dates c'est ce qu'on appelle
la sérénité des faits est-ce que si ces
liens sont établis ça risque de changer
la donne pour bon nombre d'affaires en
cours
oui ça changera sûrement sûrement la
donne pour un certain nombre d'affaires
en cours vous faites référence à un
arrêt que je n'ai jamais lu
puisqu'il est dans un dossier
qui concerne un de mes clients mais
auquel je n'ai pas accès client qui a
fait l'objet d'un classement sans suite
pour l'instant nous en sommes là voilà
sur des faits non prescrits PPDA
donc voilà je vais pas parler de son cas
particulier mais pour venir à cette cet
arrêt-là je ne l'ai pas lu donc
j'aimerais bien le lire en entier pour
pouvoir le commenter là ce sont quelques
extraits que vous reprenez qui ont été
effectivement publiés dans la presse et
que et que j'ai lu donc je ne sais pas
comment c'est écrit et et comment s'est
présenté par la par la chambre de
l'instruction mais le jour où si ce jour
arrive je ne sais pas s'il arrivera mais
où cette
décision de justice me serait
éventuellement opposable ce qui n'est
pas évident à ce moment là je la dirai
et éventuellement je pourrais la
commenter et je pourrais éventuellement
si je pense que juridiquement il y a un
recours voilà j'aimerais vous faire
réagir à cette réflexion d'une
magistrate du siège en région parisienne
interrogée en décembre 2021 par le
journal Libération qui affirmait je cite
que la preuve ne repose pas
nécessairement sur des éléments
matériels on peut prononcer des
culpabilités à partir des témoignages
concordants
c'est exact la concordance peut peser
et je pensais que que seul la preuve de
la contrainte était exigée par la loi
qui ne suffisait pas de dire je n'étais
pas consentante encore fallait-il le
démontrer oui mais pour pour le
démontrer
vous pouvez effectivement
les juridictions les tribunaux
juridictions de jugement peuvent retenir
un certain nombre d'éléments et des
témoignages qui seraient concordants
normalement des témoignages directs des
faits donc c'est vrai c'est vrai que ce
sont des affaires où il n'y a pas de
temps si souvent que cela des
témoignages directs et en général il n'y
en a pas mais si vous avez un certain
nombre d'éléments d'un texte que vous
envoyez en disant la lassassana c'est
l'horreur qu'une amie à qui vous en avez
parlé en sortant vous êtes sorti en
pleurant que vous allez voir un médecin
en sortant enfin il y a effectivement
des donc si un homme un non seulement de
preuves
d'éléments concordants qui viennent
conforter des déclarations de personnes
s'il y a un certificat médical où on
constate effectivement des lésions etc
oui à ce moment là on peut on peut on
peut arriver à une condamnation qui est
justifiée ou pas enfin tout cela est une
question de d'analyse de dossier et
à propos de consentement la sociologue
Irène Terry propose d'introduire dans le
code pénal la notion de crédit de
véracité ce qui permettrait à celles et
ceux qui dénoncent les violences
sexuelles de ne plus être soupçonné de
mentir jusqu'à preuve du contraire
est-ce que c'est une piste à creuser
moi je pense qu'encore une fois là on
arrive à l'inversion totale de de nos
principes fondamentaux de ce qui fait le
socle de notre procédure pénale
au départ quand une femme
va déposer plainte pour un viol la
présomption de véracité dans les faits
elle existe mais de proposer comme le
fait Irène Terry d'en faire un principe
qui vient totalement bouleverser
finalement
règles de notre droit qui est que c'est
à l'accusation qu'un comble la charge de
la preuve moi je suis contre les
justices d'exceptions quelles qu'elles
soient je suis contre ce qui ferait de
ce de ces félins je dirais des faits qui
feraient l'objet d'un régime dérogatoire
et je pense que encore une fois ces
affaires doivent être jugées comme les
autres
avec la même exigence de recherche de
vérité la même exigence de respect de la
parole donnée mais la même exigence de
rechercher effectivement des indices et
des preuves d'une culpabilité Jacqueline
la font depuis la déflagration provoquée
par l'affaire Duhamel et le mouvement
Mitou MiTo inceste des femmes et des
hommes politiques se disent de plus en
plus favorables à l'imprescriptibilité
des crimes sexuelles sur mineur qu'en
pensez-vous
alors moi je pense que la prescription
des affaires
criminelles de sexuel sur mineur a été
considérablement rallongé puisque
maintenant on a droit de
déposer plainte on peut déposer 48
jusqu'à ses 48 ans donc donc je veux
dire 30 ans après sa majorité et pas et
parfois plus que cela puisque des faits
peuvent avoir eu lieu quelques années
auparavant encore je pense qu'une
justice qui intervient tardivement est
une est une justice qui n'en est plus
une ces règles de prescription elles ont
été rallongées je pense que pour les
enfants effectivement pour le coup
l'amnésie traumatique chez les enfants
je pense que ça probablement plus de de
sens et ça peut avoir un sens puis on
est dans un univers familial je pense
que je pense que c'est plus compliqué je
pense que les enfants doivent être
protégés plus que d'autres etc donc mais
je pense qu'on peut pas aller au delà
enfin je veux dire que c'est totalement
déraisonnable la prescription ça n'est
pas fait pour protéger les coupables
c'est fait pour protéger une justice qui
est un sens
et c'est un rempart contre contre
l'arbitaire c'est un rempart contre
contre des procès sans preuve bien sûr
et non je suis fondamentalement contre
et puis quand même enfin je pense quand
même à cette pauvre et le diabète mal
Inter qui s'est faite alors justement
écoutons là très bien
où sommes-nous
pour mépriser à ce point la justice je
suis parfaitement en accord avec le
ministre de la Justice et ses
déclarations d'hier on peut pas à ce
point mépriser les principes
démocratiques Eric Dupond-Moretti a dit
il est temps de siffler la fin de la
récréation c'est extraordinairement
dangereux ce qui est en train de se
passer certains se font dévorer par un
monstre qu'ils ont contribué à créer les
réseaux sociaux ne peuvent pas être
l'unique réceptacle sans filtre de cette
parole l'injustice doit intervenir et
encore ce matin nous allons arriver vers
une société de la délation madame
Rousseau n'est pas procureur général de
la nation voilà ce que dit Eric
Dupond-Moretti ce que reproche et je
peux le comprendre les féministes De
Mitou à la justice et raison pour
lesquelles elle retourne d'eau en fait
c'est la question de la prescription
quand c'est prescrit et donc il y a pas
de d'enquête policière et des juges non
non moi je c'est la fin je dirais de la
présomption d'innocence c'est un travail
sérieux et ben on n'est pas non plus
vous interroger pourquoi on porterait
pas plainte avant la prescription enfin
je veux dire et ah ben il pouvait pas
parler les femmes se taisent c'est tout
pardon parfois les femmes se taisent
aussi prendre ses responsabilités je
comprends très bien que pendant un
certain temps même des années ça soit
impossible à évoquer mais quand même 10
ans
bien plus que 10 ans alors la philosophe
effectivement Elizabeth Badinter s'est
fait incendier sur les réseaux sociaux
après ces propos
sur me to-politique qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez parce que certaines avocats
considèrent qu'effectivement c'est très
violent ces propos là
[Musique]
je suis absolument d'accord avec elle
sur le fait que ce que l'on veut en fait
anéantir c'est dans ces affaires là la
présomption d'innocence bien non elle
doit exister et c'est ça le combat qui
est un combat difficile et je partage
totalement ce qu'elle a dit est-ce que
vous pensez comme d'autres que la
prescription peut justement aider la
parole à émerger que c'est une
incitation
mais écoutez je pense que ça peut être
une incitation
je veux dire que cette prescription elle
est non pas de 10 ans mais mais de 20
ans et deux on a 30 ans pour les pour
les mineurs donc elle est quand même
déjà extrêmement longue ensuite il y a
une idée de la justice est-ce que ça a
un sens ces procès si longtemps après
dans des affaires où il est déjà
difficile d'avoir des preuves juste
après l'effet donc après n'en parlons
même pas ça ne te donnait lieu qu'à des
frustrations
ça n'a pas de ça n'a pas ça n'a pas de
sens et puis par ailleurs oui ça doit
inciter les femmes à déposer plainte
dans des affaires ou par exemple il y a
30 40 90 personnes qui viennent se
plaindre de fait dire que comment vous
expliquer qu'il y en a 90 qui qui n'est
pas eu l'idée pas une de déposer plainte
dans le délai de la prescription je veux
dire que
on doit aussi s'interroger enfin il faut
il faut dire les choses et vous que 90
femmes n'est pas osé porter plainte
avant les délais de prescription alors
que ces femmes là n'ont mais certaines
d'entre elles disent elles-mêmes que à
l'époque elles n'ont pas eu conscience
de ça et donc donc on revisité chose si
vous voulez moi je suis prête à parler
de toutes les affaires que vous voulez
qui ont lieu là aujourd'hui celle-ci on
en entend beaucoup moins parler voilà
beaucoup moins parlé moi je suis en
train d'accompagner une jeune femme qui
a fait l'objet d'un vieux des serra je
savais qu'elle je suis aux côtés de
plein de femmes bien sûr c'est normal je
l'ai je les accompagne dans ces faits là
j'en accompagne certaines même qui sont
venus me voir pour pour des affaires qui
étaient qui étaient prescrites mais je
suis toujours claire je suis toujours en
cohérence avec moi-même c'est à dire que
quel que soit le côté de la barre vous
trouvez j'ai toujours le même discours
toujours quand la journaliste Élise
Lucet insiste sur le fait qu'il n'existe
pas de prescription journalistique
qu'est-ce que cela vous inspire
franchement
Élise Lucet
des émissions qu'elle a consacré à
certains certaines de ces affaires
médiatiques certaines sont à mon cabinet
je pense que ce sont
des délinchages des lynchages en règle
quoi dans laquelle dans lesquels il n'y
a aucune place pour une autre parole
au point que moi je renonce totalement à
l'apprendre il n'y a pas de classe pour
ça c'est dire que vous êtes enfermé dans
quelque chose de compliqué c'est à dire
que si vous portez une autre parole vous
êtes disqualifié si vous venez
simplement rappeler des choses évidentes
basiques telles que les principes vous
êtes disqualifié vous êtes accusés
d'être contre ce combat là vous êtes
bien malgré tout les journées sont un
rôle à jouer depuis l'affaire Dreyfus on
sait que les enquêtes peuvent amener à
des ouvertures de poursuites de
procédures
oui depuis l'affaire Dreyfus vous savez
temps je me dis mais c'est là que les
choses changent c'est à dire que je veux
dire en fait
quels sont les depuis outre
j'essaie de chercher une affaire ou des
journalistes avaient recherché une
innocence
j'en ai pas trouvé
il y a des principes qui sont qui
doivent être sacrés or ils ne sont plus
aujourd'hui on s'affranchit de ces
principes au nom de la noblesse d'un
combat et derrière la noblesse de son
combat on voit resurgir des choses que
je trouve quand même encore une fois pas
forcément très très belle et très
respectable toujours voilà c'est encore
une fois cette volonté de mort sociale à
chaque fois que je me lève pour défendre
quelqu'un je me dis que je suis à ma
place il faut y croire quand on entre
dans la reine c'est ce que vous disiez
sur France Inter vous arrive-t-il
parfois d'en douter vous savez je doute
beaucoup
je doute beaucoup je doute avant chaque
plaid après chaque plaidoirie je pense
que le doute c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui doit vous accompagner c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas facile d'être
habité par le doute en permanence sur
soi sur ses capacités sur ce qu'on fait
bien ce qu'on fait mal le terrain moi le
doute m'accompagne voilà pour tout dans
tout le temps donc évidemment dans mon
dans mon métier en revanche je ne doute
jamais
qu'un homme ou une femme doit toujours
être défendu je n'ai jamais autant envie
de défendre les gens que lorsqu'ils sont
accablés lyncher parfois on me dit mais
arrête de défendre un tel un tel etc
mais en fait je je pense que oui voilà
quand on défend on est on est un peu
seul contre tous c'est dur par moment
c'est c'est dur mais
mais je pense que le jour où j'aurais
plus envie de faire ça pendant que
j'arrête d'être avocat aussi